chinese authorities have imposed their
most severe lockdown in almost a year
13 million people living in the northern
city of xi'an have been ordered to stay
home from midnight on thursday
only one member of each household is
allowed out to get food every two days
and only certified essential workers can
head out for work
the measures prompted crowds to rush to
grocery stores and markets earlier this
week
more than 200 cases have been reported
in the city since the beginning of the
month
the outbreak of the delta variant began
with just nine people and quickly spread
the trajectories of the night cases were
complex involving transportation
services and public places including
hospitals commercial complexes
restaurants and schools
hundreds of thousands of tourists flock
to xi'an a former capital and historic
hub to see the terracotta warriors every
year
now almost all transport in and out of
the area has been cancelled
residents must apply for special
permission to leave the city
authorities are currently conducting
their third round of mass testing
so far no cases of the omicron variant
have been locally transmitted in china
but officials here are on high alert the
beijing winter olympics opens in
february and chinese leaders have
promised a safe and secure games where
spectators will be able to attend
overseas spectators however won't be
attending china has maintained its zero
tolerance approach to the virus and
borders have been closed since march
last year
during the winter olympics there will be
a large number of olympic affiliated
individuals from different countries and
regions coming to china there is a high
possibility that a certain number of
kovi 19 positive cases will arise
more than 80 percent of the country's
population have received two doses of
coronavirus vaccines
officials are now encouraging people to
get a third shot
but some studies have found that chinese
vaccines have lower efficacy and
protection rates against the omicron
strain
beijing has not approved the use of some
other vaccines such as pfizer or
astrazeneca
katrina you al jazeera beijing